gird your loins everybody it's the 10th
anniversary of The Devil Wears Prada and
we're still watching it roughly once a
week that's just you Ashley fair enough
did you drink your hot Starbucks this
morning no I did not but I did have a
cube of cheese well that's good you
don't want to faint nope this movie
taught us some valuable life lessons
like how all my clothes are crap I'm
sorry to have some pride commitment some
hideous skirt convention you after that
Emily Blunt is and always will be a stop
you eat God's Christ babe we learned how
to spell Kasana
hello guess not
we learned what I'll run through it to
run through a huge deal I don't know why
you don't know that country and of
course we're cerulean comes from you're
wearing a sweater that was selected for
you by the people in this room from a
pile of stuff oh and the most important
lesson of all do not move at a glacial
pace never do you know how that thrills
me but we still have some questions
please bore someone else with your
questions like why was Nate and her
friends such unsupportive piece of crap
you didn't have to
and why was Nate spending so much money
on it cheese give me that it's like $8
and Jarlsberg in there but there is one
question we never got the answer to did
do Marshall yet confirmed did the
Marshall yay ever confirm - Marshall
yeah did he get get him on the phone
anybody know tweet us let us know or
just give us a sequel Meryl